here at the amber weapon show we've
recently met with nbc universal's
attorney
matt strong look at him isn't he cute
matt explained to us that for legal
reasons it's important to always make a
clear distinction
between fact and opinion so we'd like to
do that now in a segment called
fact and opinion
fact in a recent statement on their
website the cdc recommended that
americans avoid
door-to-door trick-or-treating this
halloween opinion
adults should not celebrate halloween if
you want some candy buy a bag and eat it
don't get a bunch of strangers involved
fat mitch mcconnell has served in the
u.s senate for 35 years
opinion the high point of those 35 years
was this
[Applause]
oh
how did you somehow make your face look
right
[Laughter]
because i love you okay you guys fact
a town in new york called swastika
recently voted
not to change its name opinion if you're
driving through the town of swastika
do not get out of the car fact
okuvier's beaked whale recently broke a
world record by staying underwater for
three hours and 42 minutes
opinion he should have stayed down there
longer there's nothing good up here
fact cardinal angelo bechu a powerful
cardinal at the vatican
recently resigned in the midst of a
scandal
opinion the scandal is that he won't let
me borrow that hat
it's probably something really really
serious and
finally fact there are 32 days until the
election
opinion there are 30 bajillion d days
until the election
this has been fact an opinion
i'm matt strong a real life lawyer and i
approve this segment
he is so cute i can't deal with it
[Music]
you